[Music]
electricity Conn competitor I feel when
I'm with you
thank you for electricity like it was
the last minute summer beggar that we
needed you know thank you very much I'm
really proud of that song and I'm proud
of the video
[Music]
and you went blonde for a hot second I
mean were you enjoying that it was awake
I know I bought it it makes it makes for
a great you pulled it off though like is
this something you would ever consider
permanently ah you know we exist
why do it why do it don't ruin your hair
right do a leaper may not be ready to go
blonde but she's already hard at work on
her next album yeah if you're recording
um quite a bit I feel good about it yeah
um it's still you know it's a pop album
but it's a bit different to the first
one it's got some more nostalgic pipes
about it burn you know I'm still on the
process of writing it and finishing it
off but I'm very excited about it do you
think we'll get bored love songs on this
next one I mean I see you you and your
man on Instagram you seem like you're in
love and you know there's there's
something really nice about love in
general but you know everything I write
about there will be a mixture of some
happy ones and some sad ones and it's
all about digging into the memory box
and kind of picking out different
moments in your life that you know has
kind of impacted you in a different way
where you feel like you know me speaking
about this experience will also make
somebody else it would maybe help
somebody else that was one of the things
that really pushed me to write the way I
do and so that's something that I'm
gonna keep doing if I feel like it's
gonna have an importance to lyrics
really struck a chord with people I mean
I feel like there's fans out there who
are really following those rules you
know what
don't pick up the phone you know he's
only coming cuz he's drunk
don't be in the morning we've only used
them at some point and you're much
better at giving advice than taking your
own do you feel like the rules can
evolve like could we get like a new
rules follow up on the second album you
know I think they just live just that
little yeah you know three simple rules
I feel like you don't need to you need
you don't need to go in tomorrow
[Music]